I love this city
and I see it going to hell sometimes I
think this place is cursed I won't let
it fall apart without a fight
citizens of Gotham we will not we cannot
let these killers these robbers these
rapist and these thugs with not on my
watch
there's a war coming a terrible war
there will be chaos rivers of blood in
the streets
I know it
that's my new partner Jim Gordon you
have a little danger in your eye
I wonder what you plan to do with that
you kill people before
that was war this is more World War
- no my name is Bruce Wayne I promise
you I will find the man who did this
I'm learning to conquer fear fear
doesn't need conquering fear tells you
where the edges
somebody has to take over it might as
well be me Gotham is on a knife edge
this is not a city for nice guys
cabron shout
however dark and scary the world might
be right now there will be light there
will be lighting for us
hey youtubers is Charlie so the first
trailer for Gotham just dropped last
night so I wanted to do a breakdown
basically I'm thinking about it like
arrow told from Quentin's perspective
except this you know much much darker
it's basically going to be a dark cop
drama doir thriller with superheroes
kind of floating around in the ether in
the background I know a lot of you have
been asking me to if I think that it's
sustainable if they can make it for five
seasons so I'll address that too if you
ever read Batman you're 1 the comic or
saw the cartoon movie they made think of
this is like detective Gordon Year one
although technically the series picks up
right when Bruce Wayne's parents are
being killed I would expect that to go
down in that first episode so this is a
Fox show and they had to pay a dumptruck
of money to get all the comic book
characters they use but they did get a
lot of really good ones not the Joker
though there is no Joker right now the
roster is Ben McKenzie as Gordon I never
watched him on Southland but I'm gonna
give him a chance I'm very optimistic
Jada Pinkett Smith as fish Mooney she's
gonna be a gangster but not from the
comics in the universe that the show's
creating she's the boss of the penguin
who's being played by Robin Lord Taylor
so it's like a very very young Oswald
Cobblepot I'm really curious to see if
he gets his penguin nickname on the show
or if they'll have it in that first
episode if arrow has been any indicator
though most of the characters will just
start out as their real-world personas
and evolve into the comic book
characters over time which I'm totally
fine with going down the rest of the
list there's also the Selina Kyle
Catwoman played by Cameron beaconed OVA
she's not related to Michelle Pfeiffer
I totally swear but the resemblance is
uncanny so I'm excited to see what kind
of energy she channels into it Alfred
Pennyworth is being played by Sean
Pertwee you might have seen him as the
dirtbag version of Lestrade on
elementary he's a lot beefier than
Jeremy Irons who's playing Alfred in
Zack Snyder's Man of Steel sequel this
version of Alfred I think is going to be
the ex British military version that we
saw the animated series explore a long
time ago so expect him to be a much more
punchy smashy Alfred that's a big change
from the Michael Caine Dark Knight
Alfred - so let me know how you feel
about him turning into a brawler as
opposed to the you know polite society
old world British person that he used to
be personally I don't mind I think it's
going to be really interesting twists on
the character especially since Bruce
Wayne is very very young so this is
going to be a much younger Alfred Bruce
Wayne is being played
by David Mizzou's he and Selina Kyle are
going to be about the same age in the
show but here's where the cast starts to
get really interesting
so they've also cast roles for poison
ivy that's Claire Foley she's going to
be IV pepper whenever the show picks up
the Riddler is being played by Corey
Michael Smith also starting out as
Edward nygma and then there's Betty Kane
yes the bad girl Betty Kane she's going
to be played by Sara Paxton because
she's so much older than those young
comic book characters I'm really
interested to see if she turns into
Batgirl during season one and fills that
vigilante void that Batman would
normally fill but obviously you know
he's not coming along for another 10
years so someone's got to fill that void
in the meantime there's a bunch more
secondary characters too like Bullock
being played by Donal Logue Aaron
Richards is playing Barbara Kean
she's Gordon's wife and Crispus Allen is
being played by Andrew Stewart Jones
that's pretty much it for the comic book
characters in season one but if the show
makes it to season to remember what
arrow did whenever it made it to season
two we brought on the flash and we got
Black Canary so Gotham could bring on
more characters over time the show
itself was ordered to series which means
that we will see episode 1 in the fall
but they're probably going to air the
pilot at Comic Con so if you can make it
to that you will get to see it early I
will be doing weekly videos for just
like Aaron agents of shield whenever it
airs really what I'm hoping to see is a
lot of the character interactions
especially between the pre-super
characters you know like a lot of Betty
Cain Gordon scenes Jada Pinkett Smith
and Oswald Cobblepot Alfred Bruce and
Bruce and Gordon but I think what we're
really all waiting for is for Bruce
Wayne to interact with all the super
villains as young characters like young
Bruce Wayne running into Selina Kyle or
poison ivy and just seeing what kind of
dynamic they have like most comic book
characters they're not going to start
out evil so poison ivy Selina Kyle
they're just going to be normal little
kids usually they have to experience
some sort of major trauma before they
take on their villain persona so expect
Jada Pinkett Smith to do terrible things
to Oswald Cobblepot
and I'm sure that Selina Kyle is going
to be terrorized all across season 1 but
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what are you looking
forward to most you know obviously I'm
really just looking forward to seeing
this dynamic between all these young
characters it's really amazing when you
know what the end point is when you know
what their end game is as for them
making it to four or five seasons I
think they can do it but one of the big
issues they have is having to pay warner
brothers extra money on
top of the production for all those
comic book characters arrow on the other
hand is made by the CW owned by Warner
Brothers so they do not have a lot of
the added cost that Gotham will have the
idea though is that Fox being a major
network has a much larger audience so
hopefully they can make up the money in
advertising honestly I think we'll know
whether or not we're going to get a
season 2 after the first couple of
episodes but I will be doing weekly
videos whenever it starts airing be sure
to subscribe to get those and I'll be
doing bonus videos in the meantime - be
sure to leave me suggestions for what
you want those bonus videos to be about
right now click here to catch up on
arrow there's only two episodes left and
it's been really freaking good this
season and click here to catch up on
agents of shield there's also only two
more episodes left so thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you